[Música]
sigue siendo incierto donde está el
obispo nicaragüense Rolando Álvarez en
nuestra sección en contexto analizamos
un poco más de quién es el religioso Y
qué le ha pasado las versiones oficiales
señalan que como está en el mapa el
religioso se encuentra en el sistema
penitenciario nacional Jorge Navarro
conocido como la cárcel la modelo esta
está ubicada en el municipio de tipitapa
a 22 km de la capital esas mismas
Fuentes sostienen que habría sido
trasladado durante unas horas en la
noche del lunes a la conferencia
episcopal de Nicaragua que está ubicada
en Managua pero la entidad religiosa no
ha dicho nada al respecto recordemos que
el proceso contra el obispo comenzó
durante las protestas contra el gobierno
de Daniel Ortega que se dispararon en
abril de 2018 Álvarez Fue una de las
voces más críticas durante estas
manifestaciones y uno de los mediadores
Durante los diálogos que hubo
posteriormente Ortega sin embargo ha
afirmado que Álvarez está a favor del
imperialismo desde comienzos de agosto
de 2022 la policía desplegó agentes
alrededor de la casa cural de la
diócesis de matagalpa y el día 19 de ese
mes allanaron el recinto sin orden
judicial desde entonces el obispo
Álvarez estuvo en prisión domiciliaria y
cuando el gobierno nicaragüense desterró
a los primeros 222 presos políticos
hacia Estados Unidos la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
señala que el obispo habría sido sacado
de su casa para montarlo en el avión en
el que iban los desterrados Pero como se
negó a salir del país lo llevaron a la
cárcel la modelo ese mismo día y menos
de 24 horas después lo condenaron a 26
años y cuatro meses de prisión por
cuatro delitos incluidos menos cabo la
integridad nacional desobediencia y
propaga de noticias falsas a sus
sobrinas y a su hermana no les
permitieron ningún contacto con el
religioso y solo hasta el 24 de marzo es
decir 43 días después de haber entrado
en la prisión les permitieron visitarlo
sus abogados afirman que el líder
católico estuvo en aislamiento total
antes y después de ese encuentro
Familiar El Obispo volvió a ser noticia
este miércoles cuando Fuentes
diplomáticas anónimas afirmaron en
diferentes medios de comunicación que
Rolando Álvarez había sido excarcelado
en la noche del lunes tres de Julio esa
versión señala que como otra vez se negó
a salir del país lo habrían devuelto a
la modelo pero no hay ninguna prueba de
ello si les gustó este en contexto Los
invito a que Comenten en las redes
sociales que verán en sus pantallas y
también nos pueden sugerir los temas de
los que quieran saber más y aquí en
France 24 los estaremos escuchando